authorities say that actor alec baldwin
shot and killed a woman on the set of
his upcoming film rust in new mexico the
woman was the film's cinematographer the
director was also wounded according to
the stage actors union baldwin's prop
gun contain quote a single live round
court documents state that before fatal
shooting alec baldwin was handed a
loaded gun on the film set by a director
who wasn't aware it was loaded
fox news digital has just obtained a 911
call from a script supervisor on the set
and the script supervisor can be heard
blaming an assistant director for
failing to make sure the prop gun was
safe here's a part of that call
so was it loaded with a real bullet or
one yeah i don't i cannot tell you that
okay we have two injuries from a movie
done
shot okay we're getting them out there
already just stay on the phone with me
okay
that yelled at me at lunch because
asking about revisions
did you see anything over my chest and
yell at me
he's supposed to check the gun she's
responsible
deadline is now reporting that there had
been a recent accidental discharge of
the prop gun on the set and the la times
is reporting that crew members walked
off the set just hours before the
shooting one crew member was reportedly
complaining about gun safety
tim clementi is a hollywood technical
consultant and former fbi special agent
and he joins us now so tim
on a legitimate movie set with safety
protocols when you're dealing with a
prop gun
what would go into something like using
a gun during the filming
the first thing jesse is always the
safety rules there's four rules of
firearm safety that you follow with any
gun treat every weapon if it's as if
it's loaded never point a gun at
anything you're not willing to kill or
destroy never put your finger on the
trigger unless you're killed willing to
kill or destroy and always be aware of
what's in front of behind and around
your target all four of those rules were
violated on that movie set and if you
follow those rules nobody's in danger
and nobody gets hurt and i don't know
that alec baldwin is to blame the
producers the the a.d that that woman
mentioned the assistant director
there's probably a whole host of people
because this is a cascading set of
issues that led to this happening
clearly it wasn't just alec having the
gun in his hand it was him not knowing
that it was possibly loaded him not
treating it like it was loaded
and you know he bears a little bit of
responsibility as a producer on set to
make sure these things are being done
and clearly they weren't
so one round
i guess
wounded one person and killed another
are you thinking it was some sort of
ricochet situation
well generally the director and the
director of photography are in very
close proximity to each other on the set
they're usually right next to the camera
or right behind the camera or somewhere
very close by and it's possible that it
was one round but possibly not a bullet
there could have been something else
another shell casing that was in the gun
i understand
since this is a i guess a
period piece that is most likely that it
was a revolver and so it is possible
that the wrong caliber was put in first
or something else was introduced into
the chamber which was still in the
chamber and then a blank was put into
the cylinder the cylinder
rotates the gun fires and whatever's in
that in that barrel can be projected
down the barrel that could fragment and
hit two people at the same time or it
could literally go through one person
into the other
and it looks like sloppiness because
there was another incident apparently
days earlier where there was a discharge
situation that people were concerned
about and you know investigators are
going to look at everything they're
going to look at sloppiness they're
going to look at sabotage i think
everything is on the table here you
don't have a loaded weapon on a set like
that and treat it that cavalierly
without multiple protocols being
violated
it's just such a tragedy and
i don't see any sort of real explanation
besides little
leaks that we're hearing throughout the
day
in your opinion and you've
you're familiar with this kind of
situation
what does your gut tell you about what
happened
well i think there again there's a
failure there's supposed to be a prop
master there's usually an armorer
whenever you have weapons on set both of
those people are very responsible
ordinarily and they would be the person
that you would go to
with the weapon before and after you're
going to use it and so somebody should
have handed the actor in this case alec
baldwin a weapon and said alec this is
loaded don't point it in anybody don't
put your finger on the trigger when you
shoot it make sure you're pointing it in
a safe direction it's got a blank in it
and this you know it can still cause
harm
and then alex should have recognized
that once the shot is done the gun is
taken away by the prop master the armor
or whoever's responsible on set clearly
there was none of that apparently during
a rehearsal he was holding the gun in
his hand and i don't know if this
accident occurred during the rehearsal
or during an actual uh scene they were
filming but either way there's as i said
there's several people that are
responsible and i think one of the
reasons we're not hearing a lot of
detail coming out is because there could
be criminal liability absolutely i don't
i don't disparage i don't disparage any
of the people involved as as individuals
right but there are
there are ramifications when something
like this happens and unfortunately it
can be criminal right and according to
the 9-1-1 call it looks like it wasn't
the armorer or the prop master that
handed the gun it was the assistant
director so all of those things were not
followed tim thanks so much for the
insight